Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute Mochi Eis!
Also ich hab Mochis das erste Mal vor ca zwei Jahren gegessen, da hat eine Freundin das -
also fertig gekauft mitgebracht und ich fand es ganz cool.
Es ist gewöhnungsbedürftig denn Mochis bestehen eigentlich aus einem - so einer Teighülle,
so einem Teigmantel aus Klebreismehl und innen drin gibt es dann verschiedene Füllungen.
Und ganz neu ist jetzt eben das Mochi Eis. Und das machen wir jetzt, passt natürlich
zum anstehenden Sommer und ich habe jetzt hier die Zutaten für meinen Teig.
Und er ist auch einfacher als ihr jetzt vielleicht vermuten mögt, wir brauchen auch nur drei Zutaten.
Die wichtigste Zutat ist das Klebreismehl. Es gibt auch Reismehl aber ihr müsst unbedingt darauf achten,
dass es Klebreismehl ist. Das gebe ich jetzt in eine große Schüssel
und dazu kommt Wasser. Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen hier unten
in der Videobeschreibung. Das Wasser gebe ich mit dazu und Zucker gebe ich auch schon mit dazu.
Und Wasser ist bei mir übrigens lauwarm, so verbindet sich das Ganze besser.
So, das ist die Konsistenz nach 30sek, hier dürfen keine Klümpchen mehr drin sein!
Und jetzt gehen wir rüber zum Herd.
So, den noch flüssigen Teig geben wir dann in eine beschichtete Pfanne
und jetzt ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr nur die mittlere Stufe nehmt, also ich bin maximal bei Stufe 5 von 9.
Und dann dauert das Ganze 10min, ich habe extra die Zeit gestoppt. 10min bis ihr diese Konsistenz erreicht.
Also ich zeig's euch mal von nahem, das müsst ihr einfach sehen. Das kann ich nicht so gut beschreiben.
Also so klebrig ist dann der Teig. Und wichtig ist, dass ihr eben mit einem Teigschaber
oder mit 'nem Kochlöffel, dass ihr ihn da immer wieder hin- und herschiebt
damit euch das am Boden nicht anpappt. Und jetzt möchte ich meinen Teig
bevor ich das Ganze weiterverarbeite einfärben. Das mache ich mit Lebensmittelgelfarben.
Dafür habe ich mir hier drei Schüsseln bereitgelegt und werde jetzt den Teig jetzt einmal durch drei teilen.
Die Farben haben auch so ein bisschen was mit meiner Füllung gleich zu tun aber das zeige ich euch nachher!
Jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen Tapiokastärke, wenn ihr die nicht habt, dann könntet ihr auch
Kartoffelstärke nehmen. Ich glaube die findet man eher in den Supermärkten aber ich hatte das jetzt da
und geb das jetzt hier einfach auf meine Arbeitsfläche.
Auch nicht geizen weil es ist schon ein sehr klebriger Teig!
Und dann verteilen wir einfach unsere drei Teige darüber.
So und jetzt lasst ihr das ganz kurz auskühlen, das habe ich jetzt gemacht.
So ungefähr 10min, dann könnt ihr auch drauftippen und es klebt nicht mehr so doll! Und -
(H: Ich schwöre es dir, ich weiß bis jetzt nicht was Mochis ist...)
(H: und ich hab keine Ahnung, was du da machst!)
Ernsthaft?
(H: Und ich find das voll interessant!)
Okay krass, okay interessant! Dann bin ich mal
gespannt wie du es findest ganz am Ende!
(H: Ich lass mich überraschen!)
Also wir machen jetzt folgendes: ich nehme mir jetzt meine Teigkarte
und dann teile ich jeden Teig - es kommt darauf an, wollt ihr große oder kleine Mochis? Hmm, was mache ich?
Durch 3 oder durch 4? Ich kann ja immer noch rumswitchen! ich mache erst mal durch 3.
So, nachdem ihr dann alle Mochiteige geformt habt, einfach -
(H: Und Mehl in den Haaren habt!)
Mehl in den Haaren?
(H: Ja! Ist nicht so schlimm, weiter komm!)
Können wir sie einfach - also hier müsst ihr euch auch keinen Stress machen, hier müsst ihr euch nicht beeilen.
Allerdings hole ich jetzt kurz Hackfleisch und dann geht's weiter!
It's a prank, it's a prank!
(H: Ich wollt grad sagen: Hackfleisch?!)
Ihr hättet Hamzas Gesicht sehen müssen! Er so: M-mh...
(H: Das ist doch süß! Ist das nicht was süßes?)
Ja es ist was süßes aber Hamza hat ja keine Ahnung was Mochis sind, deswegen dachte ich
ich prank dich mal kurz!
(H: Ja ich hab schon ne Ahnung was es wird!)
Es wird was süßes! Ich hol jetzt Eis.
Wenn ich das Eis hole, müssen wir uns natürlich beeilen.
Also ich geh ganz kurz zum Gefrierfach und dann sehen uns gleich wieder!
So, jetzt schnappt ihr euch eure Lieblingseiskugeln. Ich habe mich für Erdbeer, Vanille und Cookie Dough
entschieden. Richtig lecker!
Einfach mit 'nem Eisportionierer reingeben und dann langsam verschließen.
Allerdings dürft ihr auch nicht so viel Handwärme abgeben weil das Eis schmilzt ja natürlich auch!
So, ich probiere jetzt mal für euch. Ich nehm' mir einfach mal Vanille.
Ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen geschmolzen, aber...mmh!
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an Kaugummi!
(H: Vielleicht dieses Bubble, Bubble Gum? Wie heißt das nochmal? Dieses Bubble Eis?)
Kann sein, aber - also diese äußere Hülle erinnert mich so von der Konsistenz
auch ein bisschen ein Kaugummi. Und innen ist natürlich dass Eis, was ihr euch aussucht.
Das sollte natürlich ein hochwertiges Eis sein, das sollte lecker schmecken
weil da ist ja der Geschmack ganz klar.
Aber ich persönlich find's ganz cool. Könnte man echt mal auch zusammen mit Freunden machen
und halt auch immer im Gefrierfach lagern.
Dann könnt ihr euch immer wenn ihr Lust habt auf Mochi Eis, könnt ihr euch das rauskramen.
Das geht natürlich auch mit anderen Varianten. Was hast du für Ideen? Was fruchtiges?
(H: Ich will einfach nur dass du schnell das Video beendest damit ich auch probieren kann
bevor es schmilzt.)
Okay. Okay, okay, okay. Hamza probiert jetzt auch. Ansonsten könnt ihr alle Varianten nehmen.
Mango, Maracuja oder Schokolade, alles was ihr möchtet!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen und wir sehen uns dann
bei meinem nächsten Rezept! Tschüss, eure Kiki!
Jetzt muss ich mir erstmal die Hände sauber machen!
(H: Und dein Gesicht und deine Haare!)
Ehrlich? Immer noch?
(H: Etwas!)
Oh nein!
Bis dann, Tschüss!